BRET?
>> Bret: WILL COVER ALL THAT
RIGHT HERE.
LET'S GET SOME INSIGHTS FROM
OHIO CONGRESS MIN JIM JORDAN,
THE RANKING REPUBLICAN ON THE
HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE,
CONGRESSMAN.
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
TODAY'S HEARING FOR IT WHAT YOUR
TAKE AWAY?
>> THE FIRST TAKE AWAY IS
MICHAEL COHEN IS DELUSIONAL.
HE SAID IN THE HEARING THAT HE,
MICHAEL COHEN, IS THE ONE WHO
STARTED THE CAMPAIGN BECAUSE HE
STARTED A WEBSITE IN 2011.
YOU CAN'T TRUST ANYTHING HE
SAID.
HE ACTUALLY DISAGREED WITH WHAT
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK PROSECUTORS SAID WHEN
THEY SAID IN THEIR SENTENCING
MEMO THAT HE WAS WANTING TO GET
A JOB IN THE WHITE HOUSE PAID HE
SAID, NO, DIDN'T WANT A JOB IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHEN YOU DISAGREE WITH THE
PROSECUTOR'S AND SAYING YOU ARE
A GUY WHO WANTS THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN?
I DO NOT KNOW YOU CAN TAKE OF
MUCH OF WHAT HE SAYS THAT IN
YOUR REAL VALUE.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE
SPECIFICS OF THE HUSH PAYMENTS,
AS HE CALLED THEM, THE 11
PAYMENTS TO HIM, THE CHECKS THAT
HE BROUGHT AND SET INTO THE
RECORD.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THAT?
>> REMEMBER, BRET.
THERE WAS NO NEW EVIDENCE HERE.
IF THERE WERE NEW EVIDENCE HERE,
PROSECUTORS WILL NOT ALLOW IT TO
BE HEARD IN AN OPEN SETTING.
IT WOULD BE PART OF AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION.
THERE WAS NOTHING NEW HERE.
AND MICHAEL COHEN CANNOT HAVE IT
EVERY WAY HE WANTS.
ON ONE HAND, HE SAYS IT WAS HIS
DREAM JOB, ON THE OTHER HAND HE
SAID HE WASN'T GETTING ANY
PAYMENTS IN THE FORM OF RETAINER
OVER THE TIME PERIOD I WAS
ACTUALLY HIS PERSONAL LAWYER.
AGAIN, I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
BELIEVE OF WHAT HE SAYS.
WHAT I DO THINK WAS GOING ON
TODAY IS THAT THIS WAS THE FIRST
STEP IN THE DEMOCRATS' CRAZY
IMPEACHMENT PLAN.
UNDERSTAND THIS, BRET.
LAST WEEK, TOM STEYER, MEGA
DONOR FOR THE DEMOCRATS,
MOVING AHEAD WITH IMPEACHMENT.
TWO NIGHTS AGO, TOM STEYER WAS
IN BALTIMORE IN CHAIRMAN
CUMMINGS' DISTRICT.
URGING HIS CONSTITUENTS TO PUSH
CHAIRMAN CUMMINGS TO PUSH AHEAD
WITH IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S WHAT THIS THINGS ABOUT
TODAY, THE CRAZY IMPEACHMENT
PLAN OF THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, FORMER
NEW JERSEY GOVERNOR CHRIS
CHRISTIE WATCHED THE HEARING
TODAY.
FORMER TRUMP CONFIDANT.
HERE'S WHAT HE HAD TO SAY ABOUT
THE REPUBLICAN QUESTIONING.
>> I THINK THE INSTITUTE THING
IS THAT THERE HAS NOT BEEN MORE
REPUBLICANS YET WHO HAVE TRIED
TO DEFEND THE PRESIDENT ON THE
SUBSTANCE FOR THAT SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD BE CONCERNING FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHY ARE NO REPUBLICANS STANDING
UP FOR DEFENDING THE PRESIDENT
ON THE SUBSTANCE?
THAT'S EITHER A FAILURE OF THOSE
REPUBLICANS ON THE HILL OR A
FAILURE OF THE WHITE HOUSE TO
HAVE A UNIFIED STRATEGY WITH
THEM FOR THEY KNEW WHAT WAS
COMING WITH MICHAEL COHEN.
>> Bret: YOUR REACTION TO
THAT?
>> MICHAEL COHEN CANNOT BE
TRUSTED.
THE DEMOCRATS' FIRST ANNOUNCED
WITNESS OF THIS CONGRESS IS A
GUY WHO'S GOING TO PRISON, WILL
BE A FEDERAL INMATE IN TWO
MONTHS FOR LYING TO CONGRESS.
I MEAN, COME ON FIT WE DID HAVE
MEMBERS WHO DID DEFEND AND -- IN
PARTICULAR, CONGRESSMAN MASSEY
DID WHEN HE QUESTIONED
MR. COHEN ON, IF YOU MADE THIS
PAYMENT AND DIDN'T EVEN KNOW IF
IT WAS LEGAL OR NOT, WHAT KIND
OF LAWYER ARE YOU?
WE DID HAVE SOME MEMBERS DIG
INTO THOSE ISSUES BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS HOW CAN YOU TRUST
ANYTHING THIS INDIVIDUAL HAS TO
SAY?
>> Bret: WHEN HE REPEATEDLY
SAID HE COULD NOT TALK ABOUT
CERTAIN THINGS BECAUSE THEY ARE
UNDER INVESTIGATION BY THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK,
IS THAT NOT A RED FLAG TO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, TO THE
PRESIDENT?
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE ARE
REFERRING TO, BRET.
MAYBE HE'S REFERRING TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
WE DIDN'T GET INTO SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK OR THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
RELATIVE TO WHAT HE COULD OR
COULD NOT SAY IN TODAY'S
HEARING.
MR. CUMMINGS SAID THAT THE SCOPE
IS SO LIMITED, MR. CUMMINS SAID
THINGS HE FELT THAT MEMBERS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ASK ABOUT.
FRANKLY I THINK THEY WERE
DESIGNED TO BE THINGS THAT ONLY
MR. CUMMINGS THOUGHT WAS GOING
TO BE EMBARRASSING TO THE
PRESIDENT.
WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE
SPECIFICS.
I UNDERSTAND ALL YOUR POINTS
ABOUT CREDIBILITY.
I UNDERSTAND ALL THE THINGS
ABOUT UNDERMINING HIS VERACITY.
HE IS A FLAWED, FLAWED WITNESS.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE SUBSTANCE?
I MEAN, THE PRESIDENT WRITING A
CHECK TO HIM WHILE PRESIDENT FOR
THESE PAYMENTS, THESE 11
PAYMENTS, THAT HE SAYS WERE TO
PAY OFF STORMY DANIELS, AND THE
OTHER WOMAN --
>> BRET...
>> Bret: IS THAT NOT TRUE
>> >> Michael: SAID HE'S THE
PERSONAL LAWYER FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
THERE WAS A RETAINER INSTALLMENT
OVER THE COURSE HE WAS A TIME OF
THE PERSONAL LAWYER FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S UNUSUAL.
MY GUESS IS THEY WERE ALL KINDS
OF COMPANIES WHO HAD A SIMILAR
TYPE OF RELATIONSHIP.
THAT WAS BOUGHT OFF TODAY.
WHERE WAS THE NEW NEWS.
THERE WASN'T NEW NEWS HERE.
IF THERE WAS ANY NEW EVIDENCE,
NO PROSECUTOR WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO BE HEARD TODAY IN AN OPEN
HEARING LIKE THIS IN CONGRESS.
>> Bret: THERE WERE SOME
THINGS THAT WERE UNDER OATH THAT
PERKS SOME YEARS BECAUSE YOU HAD
HIM SAYING THAT HE NEVER WENT TO
PRAGUE.
HE DOESN'T BELIEVE OR HADN'T
HEARD OF ANYTHING ABOUT RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THERE WERE SOME THINGS THAT
REPUBLICANS WOULD SAY, HEY, WE
ARE GOING ALONG WITH THAT.
BUT YOU SAY IS CREDIBILITY IS
SHOT, RIGHT?
>> EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, YOU
GET SOME TRUTH FROM SOME PEOPLE.
>> Bret: [CHUCKLE]
>> AND TO McCABE DID SAY A
COUPLE OF THINGS ON HIS BOOK
TOUR.
HE'S DONE THAT HE SAID HE WAS
SERIOUS ABOUT INVOKING THE 25TH
AMENDMENT.
OTHER PEOPLE WE DEPOSE, THAT'S
ONE THING IN ANDY McCABE'S
STATEMENT.
BUT MAYBE HE DID SAY A FEW
THINGS THAT WERE ACCURATE.
ONE THING IS THAT HE'S NEVER
BEEN TO PRAGUE.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO
FOCUS ON THAT BECAUSE THAT GOES
RIGHT TO THE HEART OF THIS.
THE DOSSIER WAS THE KEY.
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN WHO HIRED
GLENN SIMPSON WHO HIRED THE
FOREIGNER CHRISTOPHER STEELE TO
PUT TOGETHER THE FAKE DOSSIER
WHICH THE FBI USE TO GET THE
WARRANT TO SPY ON TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN.
WHEN THAT WHOLE SCHEME FELL
APART BECAUSE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ELECTED DONALD TRUMP
PRESIDENT, THEY COME WITH THIS
PLAN.
THE LANNY DAVIS CHOREOGRAPHED
HEARING WITH MICHAEL KEOHANE,
THE STAR WITNESS WHO IS GOING TO
PRISON IN TWO MONTHS FOR LYING.
THAT'S WHAT TOOK PLACE TODAY AT
THE HEARING.
>> Bret: I HAVE TWO MORE QUICK
HEARINGS DOWN THE QUESTIONS.
YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS NO
FAULT, NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT?
>> I THINK AS ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES SAID, NO NEW NEWS
GOOD BUT SOME FAKE NEWS.
I THINK THERE'S NOTHING --
>> Bret: SECOND, DO YOU THINK
THE DEMOCRATS HAD A CHOICE TO
HOLD THIS HEARING TODAY OR WAIT
UNTIL THE PRESIDENT GOT BACK ON
U.S. SOIL?
>> THEY SHOULD'VE WAITED.
THAT'S FOR SURE.
THEY SHOULD'VE HONOR THE
REQUESTS THAT CONGRESSMAN
MEADOWS AND I HAD FOR THE
CHAIRMAN, WHY NOT BRING ROD
ROSENSTEIN IN?
HE'S THE DEPUTY'S
ATTORNEY GENERAL, OVERSEAS
NEW YORK, OVERSAW THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL UNTIL A FEW WEEKS AGO.
IT WOULD'VE BEEN NICE TO SEE
BOTH OF THEM SITTING
SIDE-BY-SIDE SO WE CAN GET THE
REAL STORY, THE FULL STORY.
THAT WOULD BE NICE INSTEAD OF A
GUY WHO'S GOT A 30 MINUTE